It's time to get back to learning.
A couple of announcements before we
get started: tomorrow there will be
a 10 minute quiz in recitation based
upon the content of homework one.
Obviously, it's not going to be a
question identical to something
you've done, but it's going to cover
that subject matter.
So, please don't bring in your
attorney if I didn't ask a question
that's identical to one
that you've worked.
Second thing, we started talking
about the periodic table,
and I believe that it's a hallmark
of any educated person in the 21st
century who is technically literate
to know the periodic table by heart.
And so, there will be another test.
It will be on the 23rd on a
Thursday, ten minutes.
You will be asked to write down the
periodic table.
But, you don't have to do the whole
table. We're going to leave out the
lanthanides and actinides.
So, this is what it's going to look
like. You'll have S block,
P block, and D block elements.
Identical to this, you can see this
was September 18.
If I could just ask if the people
can fix the video,
it's just a little bit set off to
the left here.
So, this is what you'll get.
You'll get 10 minutes to fill it in,
and people grouse about it.
They say, oh, this is rote learning.
This went out at the end of the
19th century, and so on.
And I say, no, I think any of you
should know that potassium lies
under sodium. I bet there are
people in this room who know the
lyrics to over 1,
00 songs, know the number of every
individual in the National
Basketball Association,
so I think that learning some subset
of elements is not unreasonable.
Everybody's done it in the past.
They grouse about it when I assign
it, and they all do it within a
minute. And then,
they're proud of it and they insist
that I, not inflict,
but rather induce you,
invite you to do the same thing.
But, I don't want to leave out the
lanthanides and actinides.
So, we're going to have contests
for mnemonics.
So, lanthanum,
cerium, praseodymium,
and so on. So, here's an example of
a mnemonic. So,
there will be two of these contests,
one for lanthanides, one for
actinides. Submitted by e-mail by 5
p.m. eastern daylight time to my
office to my e-mail address.
So, this is an example: lazy
college professors never produced
officially educated graduates to
dramatically help executives trim
yearly losses.
And if you remember this phrase,
I don't know why you would, but this
will help you learn the
lanthanides in order.
You can see that this obviously came
from industry.
There's a reference to executives.
There is the slur against the
academy here: lazy college
professors. I mean,
they have no idea how hard we work,
and look at this gigantic split
infinitive, to dramatically help.
We can do better. So, this is 3.
91 winners from previous years.
This is one. [LAUGHTER] Clearly,
this was not referring to the 3.09
professor.
There's other ways to take chemistry
at MIT. In fact,
there's a whole chemistry department
full of loony chemistry professors.
Here's another one. This one
piqued my interest.
I like the engineering theory of it.
That's what I liked.
But now, this is the piece de
resistance. I've been doing this
for many years,
and all of a sudden comes a sonnet.
There are 14 f-block elements, and
an Elizabethan sonnet
contains 14 lines.
Well, OK, this looks good,
and so there is the cerium,
praseodymium, neodymium, you know,
three stanzas, four lines apiece
with the rhyming couplet at the end.
But what's really shocking is when
you compare this with this,
it's based upon sonnet 57 because
lanthanum is element 57.
This is really, really good.
And, I mean, I wouldn't just give
it to him because he wrote a sonnet.
But there were some key points here.
You see he mentioned smelting.
And, as an extractive metallurgist,
that took the cake. When he said
smelting, I said,
OK, you got it. So,
I think this is something to think
about. We'll wait before we go to
that one, blank on that one.
So, the contest, the prizes are
neckties, and ladies' scarves.
They're very hot.
They're black with colored elements
of the periodic table.
It's very nice. Don't laugh,
I'll bring samples next date. They
really look sharp,
very sharp. There's all kinds of
gift giving coming down the road.
You never know when one of these
could just do the trick.
So, don't fail to enter.
And, I will have office hours today
starting at about 3:30 to 4:30 if
you want to see me.
By all means, go to your own
recitation instructor as well.
So, last date we were looking at
some early taxonomy,
and then on to a little bit more
about the interior of the atom.
And, we looked at the
representation of elements in the
periodic table where we have the
proton number,
z, which is equal to the number of
electrons in the neutral atom,
and the atomic mass which is the sum
of the proton number and the neutron
number. We talked about
isotopes, and whatnot.
Today, I want to continue.
So far, we've put looking at static
elements. But most people think of
chemistry as involving reactions.
So, let's look at dynamics,
reactions between chemicals.
So, how would we describe a
chemical reaction?
What are the rules?
Well, the first thing you do is you
write an equation.
And, the equation is subject to
these constraints.
First of all, we invoke Dalton's
Law.
We invoke Dalton's Law of molar
proportions, and secondly we write
it subject to conservation of mass.
We write it subject to conservation
of mass. And,
I mean literally,
mass, not mole number.
And, let's look at this.
This is probably best seen by
example. So, let's look
at a simple one.
This is the calcination of limestone.
Limestone is calcium carbonate,
and at about 900íC, calcium
carbonate decomposes to give lime or
calcium oxide plus carbon dioxide
**CaCO3 -->CaO + CO2**.
And, this is used as the first step
for making cement concrete.
And so, when you think about how
much cement concrete are consumed
annually on the planet,
this becomes a considerable point
source of greenhouse gas emissions.
And as you know,
carbon dioxide is implicated as a
greenhouse gas.
And, there's a huge amount of CO2
that comes from this process.
This is also used in steelmaking
and so on. So,
anything on the left side of the
equation is called a reactant,
and anything on the right side of
the equation is called a product.
So, the products react to give us
reactants.
And, just to show some of the hidden
balance here, here we have one mole.
I don't put a one in front. We
just take one for granted.
So, there's 1 mole of calcium
carbonate. That gives us 1 mole of
calcium oxide and 1 mole of carbon
dioxide. So, here we have 2 mole,
and here we have 1 mole. So, what's
the conservation of mass if we
divide by the atomic masses here?
We will get 100.
g of calcium carbonate and then
discover that we have 56.
g of calcium oxide, and 44 g of
carbon dioxide.
So, clearly, mass is conserved,
not mole numbers. And, if you have
trouble balancing equations,
you can look in section 2.11 in the
text. And, they go through some
mechanics. But now,
I want to look at what happens when
things are not in proper proportion.
So, in other words, what happens if
we put a bunch of elements,
compounds into a reactor but they
are not in the balanced amounts?
And so, for that,
I want to look at the production of
titanium by the Kroll process.
And, this involves the reaction of
titanium tetrachloride with
magnesium to form magnesium chloride
plus titanium **TiCl4 + 2 Mg --
2 MgCl2 + Ti**. And, this was
invented in 1937 by W. J. Kroll.
While he was still in Luxembourg,
just before World War II broke out,
he emigrated to the United States
and finished his career in the
Pacific Northwest where he helped
make huge quantities of titanium.
And, this reaction is performed in
a giant batch type reactor in which
you feed titanium tetrachloride and
magnesium and heat to about 900íC.
And, as the reaction goes,
we'll have some magnesium liquid
sitting on top of magnesium chloride
liquid, and then chunks of titanium
solid forming at the bottom with
titanium chloride gas above.
And, this is a really clever
reaction because titanium
tetrachloride is a gas.
So, it's obviously buoyant.
Magnesium is a liquid but it's less
dense than magnesium chloride.
So, as these products form, they
continue to fall out of the way and
keep this interface open.
So, the reaction can keep going.
And at the end of the reaction, you
have the reactor consumed of
titanium tetrachloride magnesium.
You have salt on top, and you have
titanium on the bottom.
And, this is what the stuff looks
like. Earlier this summer I was at
a smelter in Japan,
the largest titanium smelter on the
planet. And this is coming out of
one of these reactors.
This is both 3 m across,
and about 6 m tall. This is
titanium sponge that comes out of
the bottom of this reactor,
and it subsequently re-melted in a
vacuum arc furnace.
And, these are giant billets of
solid titanium weighing tens of tons.
OK, so let's say some young
engineer is on the job the first day
and says, OK, let's put in 200 kg of
tickle, and let's put in about 25 kg
of mag. I'm using the typical terms.
Nobody says titanium tetrachloride.
It's tickle. This is mag. I had a
graduate student.
She was a brilliant Ph.
. student of mine and she had two
dogs.
This is parenthetical.
And, she loved metallurgy as I do,
and she named one of her dogs Maggie,
and one of her dogs Molly,
magnesium and molybdenum. Boy,
you have no sense of humor
whatsoever. Either that or you are
dog lovers and you are offended by
giving them metallic names.
I don't know. All right, so what
happens? What does this engineer
give us? What is the yield?
What is the yield?
OK, so what we have to do is get
back underneath this reaction,
and see what the molar quantities
are. So, titanium tetrachloride,
magnesium, I've got 200 kg here, 25
kg here, and if I divide by the
appropriate quantities,
I'll discover I have a little over 1,
00 moles of tickle,
and I've got about 1,
00 moles of mag.
But, the reaction says I need twice
as much mag as tickle if this
reaction is going to go to
completion. Clearly,
this isn't twice that.
In fact, it's even less than that.
So, we've got a problem here. This
is much less that two times 1,
54, so therefore mag is the limiting
reagent. Mag is the limiting
reagent. And,
that's going to gate the yield.
It's going to control the yield.
The yield is going to be throttled
by magnesium. So,
how much titanium can I make?
I can only make as much titanium as
is consumed by the available
magnesium.
So, if I look at the mole ratios on
the reaction over there,
I'm going to find that I'll be able
to consume, at most,
1,029 over two, right?
Two moles of mag consume one mole
of tickle, giving us one mole of Ti,
and that's 515 moles of tickle
consumed.
And then, that produces 515 moles
titanium. And then I convert that
to mass, and that gives me 24.
kg of titanium. If I charged the
reactor in this manner,
and of course I'm assuming 100%
completion of the reaction which we
know is overly optimistic.
There may be some inefficiencies,
and at some point, if you catch me
in the hallway,
I can give you a sermon on what goes
on inside that reactor.
OK, so now the question is,
how do we know the first place that
this is a suitable reductant?
How do we know that mag will reduce
titanium tetrachloride?
Well, for this, we have to look
inside the atom.
And as I'm going to do many times
in 3.091, I'm going to start a unit
like this with a history lesson.
So, let's go back to the thrilling
days of the end of the 19th century,
and just take stock. What did we
know at the end of the 19th century
about the structure of the atom?
Well, first of all, we knew that
the atom was electrically neutral.
We knew that the negative charge is
carried by some particles called
electrons. Furthermore,
the electron has a very tiny mass in
comparison to that of the overall
atom. I mean,
the atom has a tiny mass,
too, but what we are saying is
compared to the totaled atomic mass,
the mass of the electron is tiny.
And, secondly,
the bulk of the atom is positive.
If the atom is fixed mass, the
electron is tiny, not
massive, then -
It must be the positives have all
the mass. So,
the question then is what is the
spatial distribution of charge
inside the atom?
Why do we want to know the answer
to that question?
Because that's going to give clues
as to reactivity.
So, what do we know about spatial
distribution? Well,
people took a stab at modeling it,
and the first model worth talking
about is that of J.
J. Thompson, who published this
model in 1904.
He was a professor of physics at
Cambridge University,
and he was also the director of the
Cavendish Laboratory.
Or I guess they would say
laboratory. So,
he was the director of the
laboratory, and Cavendish made a
fortune in the 1700s,
and willed it to Cambridge.
And so, they established this
laboratory in his name.
And, here's the essence of what J.
J. said.
He said that the electrons were
distributed throughout a uniformly
charged positive sphere of atomic
dimensions. So,
electrons distributed throughout --
-- a uniformly charged
positive sphere --
-- uniformly charged positive sphere,
and let me finish it,
of atomic dimension. So,
essentially you've got a positive
ball which is identical to
the size of the atom.
This was termed the plum pudding
model. This is cultural bias,
of course. This is a British term.
I've never eaten the stuff. I
don't know if I'd eat it if it were
put in front of me,
but anyways, I'm told that it looks
something like this,
that you have the custard with
little fragments of plum inside.
So, this is a positive sphere of
custard, and inside are little,
negative bits. This is the plum.
And, these bits are in motion. So,
the bulk of the atom is positive.
That's where the mass resides.
And, you get these tiny little
negatives running around.
So, the negatives are, these are
negative.
They are physically small.
They are very light, that is to say,
low mass. They are mobile.
They're moving around, and the
worst thing is that J.
J., in 1897 did the pioneering work
that got him the Nobel Prize.
He measured the charge to mass
ratio of the electron.
But, he didn't use the term of
electron. He called this negative
elemental particle the corpuscle.
He called it the corpuscle of
electric charge.
And, he kept referring to them as
corpuscles. And I'm really glad
that along came Johnstone Stony,
who was an electrochemist, the
noblest form of chemistry,
and as an electrochemist, he chose
the term for the element of an
electric charge,
the electron, coming from the Greek
word for amber because,
you know, if you rub amber you get
static charge.
So, thank goodness,
Stony triumphed. Otherwise,
we'd be talking about corpuscular
mail. You'd have c-mail.
You wouldn't have e-mail.
All right, so anyways, so all right
we have a theory.
It's 1904. What's the method of
science? You have a theory; what do
you do? Put it to the test.
So, who puts it to the test?
Ernest Rutherford. Ernest
Rutherford: he was a professor of
physics as well,
but he was at Victoria University in
Manchester just up the
road from Cambridge.
Both of these were in the UK in the
early part of the 20th century.
And, he conducted experiments to
test the plum pudding model.
Basically what he did is he took a
very thin metal foil,
and he bombarded it with charged
particles. And,
here's the Rutherford experiment.
It's taken right out of your text.
But, before I go into details, a
little bit more background
about Rutherford.
Rutherford was an interesting person.
He was born in New Zealand,
and he came from a farming family.
He was the first generation to go
to college, grew up in the farms,
and as such, he was very skilled
with machining.
He was very handy.
He was a brilliant experimentalist.
That's not to say he wasn't a
brilliant thinker,
but here the gift of a good minds
and good hands,
like the two parts of the MIT logo:
two parts rolled into one.
He did his Ph.
. He managed to get a fellowship,
and he came to the UK all the way
from New Zealand.
He got his Ph.D. under J.
J. Thompson at Cambridge. And there,
he studied radiation coming from
radioactive elements,
and he categorized to different
types of radiation,
which he termed alpha and beta,
and what he found was that the alpha
radiation as he studied it was very
good at ionizing gases whereas beta
radiation was not so good
at ionizing gases.
On the other hand,
when it came to penetrating solids,
penetrating solids, the alpha
radiation was poor at penetrating
solids, whereas the beta radiation
was very good at penetrating solids.
So, you see, this is formative
information. He understood the
interaction of particles of matter,
and that's important to set the
stage for the Rutherford experiment
in Manchester about 10 years later.
He took a job teaching,
went to another part of the British
Empire and went to Canada,
got a job at McGill. And, he worked
for a little less than 10 years at
McGill where he did more work on
these particles that radiate from
radioactive elements.
And there he was able to identify
the alpha particle as the helium
nucleus. It's helium denuded of
both of its electrons.
So, all that's left is the helium
nucleus, two protons,
two neutrons. And, for this,
he got the Nobel Prize in 1908 in
physics.
Let me just check that,
yes, no, excuse me. He got it in
chemistry. And why I'm hesitating
is, in the early days of the 20th
century, the Nobels were first given
in 1901. But,
we'll see as 3.
91 progresses, people working almost
on the same topic,
making new discoveries out of the
same lab, one of them might
subsequently win the
Nobel in physics.
One might win it in chemistry
because the disciplines weren't as
diverse as they are today.
So, that's why I hesitate.
So, he got the Nobel in chemistry,
which made him a hot property
academically. And so,
he got hired to come to the UK,
and got the job at Victoria
University after bagging a Nobel in
chemistry. By the way,
he didn't outdo his adviser,
J. J. J. J. already got his Nobel
in 1906 for that work on the
charge to mass ratio.
So, let's give him his credit,
Nobel in physics. I rather suspect
if J. J. hadn't gotten his Nobel,
it probably would have been tough
for Rutherford to get one since some
of these guys stood on the
committees. But,
it's just a speculation.
All right, so now, let's get on and
talk about the experiment.
So, what we've got here is a source
of alpha particles.
Alpha particles are these helium
nuclei, and they are the result of
radioactive decay.
So, you've got polonium or thorium
sitting inside this leaded box with
one opening. And so,
we've got a beam. And,
these particles are of extremely
high energy, very,
very high energy. And,
they strike a thin foil of metal.
And, Rutherford tried various
metals. But, the famous experiment
is attributed to the use of gold.
We've known since antiquity that
you could take gold,
and you can hammer to very,
very thin foil.
And, in this case,
they had foil that was less than a
micrometer thick.
This was 600 nanometers thick,
very, very thin. And, so the
experiment was to bombard the foil
with these alpha particles,
and that measure what happens to
them. So, we have to be able to
detect them. And so,
Rutherford had a fellow working in
his lab by the name of Geiger.
And, Geiger invented a detector.
It's called the scintillation
screen. He ultimately invented the
Geiger counter that bears his name.
But, he built a scintillation
screen, which is essentially a cloth
fiber that was covered with zinc
sulfide. And,
when zinc sulfide is hit by
particles or by anything,
by radiation or by particles of
greater than a certain critical
energy, there is a glow.
That's from the Latin word
scintilla, OK, spark.
So, you sit. You get graduate
students or some other form of cheap
labor and he had them sit in front
of the scintillation screen,
and they count. They count where
these particles hit the screen.
And then, what they did is they
made a map of where the particles
scattered once they struck the
screen. And, here's what their
findings were.
The important findings of note are
the following.
First of all, the majority of the
alpha particles were transmitted
through the screen, OK, majority,
vast majority.
Majority of alphas transmitted,
that means, when I use the term
transmitted that means passing
through in the direction that they
were originally traveling,
transmitted and some deflected
through small angles.
And, I'm going to abbreviate,
just put theta. On what else do you
use theta for,
if not angles? So,
deflected through small angles.
That's the main thing that they
observed, but there's a second thing.
And this was really,
really shocking. A tiny fraction of
the incident alpha particles were
deflected through large angles.
By large angles, I mean greater
than 90í, essentially coming back in
the direction from which they came.
OK, so tiny fraction, tiny fraction
of alphas, tiny fraction of incident
alphas, tiny fraction of incident
alphas deflected through
large angles.
And that, I mean,
greater than 90í. So,
this is called back scattering.
And, in fact, there's a technique
of analysis used today that's called
Rutherford back scattering where
people actually saw that this is a
means of identifying the substance,
the sample. The scattering is an
indication of the nature of the
substance. And,
this was a surprise because when you
take a look at what that gold foil
constitutes in the way of a
resistance to a beam of charged
particles of 7.
8 million electron volts,
when Rutherford learned of these
results, he said,
this is akin to having a 15 inch
artillery shell deflect back from a
piece of tissue paper,
to give you a sense of the relative
scales.
If you took a 15 inch artillery
shell moving at the velocity it
typically goes at,
and take that amount of kinetic
energy versus the resistive capacity
of a sheet of tissue paper,
that's the scale that we're looking
at here. It was absolutely
astonishing. So,
they thought about this,
and they said, you know, this cannot
make sense from the standpoint of
the plum pudding model.
This can't make sense because the
plum pudding model says you've got
uniformly distributed charge.
So, if I've got positive charge
uniformly distributed,
look at the choice. It's a
brilliant experiment.
He didn't shoot neutrals.
He shot alpha particles which have
a charge of plus two.
So, I've got plus twos,
zooming in at high energy against a
wall of positive charge.
And, most of the stuff goes flying
through. So, you just say,
well, this is like a bullet going
through pumpkin.
So, what's the big deal?
But, how do you explain some of
these going way,
way back. And, that's what
Rutherford says,
this can't be right.
I'm going to come up with something
else. I'm going to come up with
this model. I'm going to say that
the positive charge is not uniformly
distributed. I'm going to say,
quite to the contrary, the positive
charge is concentrated at the center
in a tiny, tiny, tiny volume.
So, I've got this tiny volume with,
in the case of gold 79 plus of
charge, and I've got some electrons
out here somewhere,
and the vast majority of the atom is
nothing. Isn't this a lot like
Democritus? Being and void,
being and void, so now I've got my
plus two little projectile coming in,
and plus two zooms right through.
But, there is a positive 79,
so the positives deflect. And so,
there is a little bit of deflection
because plus repels plus.
But once in awhile, one of these
plus twos comes in almost on axis,
and it gets whipped around by the
Coulombic repulsive forces.
So, that's Rutherford's explanation
of this set of data.
Oh, by the way,
there is a third person.
There's Rutherford, there's Geiger,
there's Marsden. Marsden is an
interesting character.
Marsden was not too different from
you. Marsden was essentially a UROP.
He'd left school for a couple of
years. He hadn't gotten his
undergrad yet.
He'd come back,
and Rutherford accepted him in his
lab. I think the man was something
like 20 years of age.
So, he says to Marsden,
take these data. I'm going to give
you the data set of the scattering
angles of the atoms.
And, he says, give me a model for
this. That's the assignment.
Get busy. So, Marsden came up with
the model, and as you go through 8.
2 and you understand electrostatics
and electrodynamics,
you'll be able to do this analysis.
B is the assumed cross-section of
the nucleus. And then, on
either side is nothing.
So, you've got a huge distance
between center to center.
And, so all Marsden is doing is
asking, what must be the,
if I've got a wall of nothing with
spots of high positive charge,
and this is my scattering data,
what must be the relative size of
the spots versus the nothing?
And, he solved the problem. And,
he concluded, let's get his name on
the board. Heck,
he deserves to have his name on the
board, Marsden.
So, Marsden concluded by his
analysis that the radius of the
nucleus, and this is Rutherford,
by the way, coining this term.
It's a nuclear model.
The radius of the nucleus as
compared to the radius of the entire
atom is on the order of about one to
10,000. So, indeed,
we are talking about a lot of void
and a tiny little bit of extremely
dense being. So,
they published this.
And, what's the result?
You would think, well, they finally
solved it, it's terrific.
Hurray! No - it's science.
They tear each other's eyes out.
The reaction to a model was
strongly negative.
Derision was the typical reaction.
They said, look, this is stupid.
First of all, this thing can't
sustain itself.
You've got a positive charge here
with a negative charge around it.
Coulomb's law says the negative
will be attracted to the positive,
and the atom will collapse. So,
that's their first objection,
nuclear collapse.
All the electrons fall into the
nucleus. The data suggests that's
what it is. The problem is that the
theory of the day can't explain it.
So, of course, theoreticians
bristle. It's Huxley that said woe
to the slaying of a beautiful theory
by an ugly fact,
nuclear collapse.
So, the Coulombic forces,
Coulombic or electrostatic forces
draw...I don't need to write it.
You know what it means.
They're Coulombic forces,
end of story. All right, number two.
Second, even if it didn't collapse,
they said you've got a radiation
problem. You've got negative charge
in motion, and it's in a circular
orbit. And, you know acceleration
means either change of speed or
change of direction.
You will learn in 8.
2 that if you have a charged body
changing direction,
that constitutes an acceleration.
And, it will be accompanied by
radiation. Radiation is the
emission of energy.
And so, again, this thing will run
out of gas. So,
an energy deficit,
accelerating charge,
the accelerating negative charge,
because it's the negatives that are
orbiting the positive center.
And that means radiation of energy,
and that energy has to come from
inside the atom itself.
So, on both counts,
they say this is no good.
It's no good. Well, time marches
on. 1912: interesting.
A young Danish scientist by the
name of Niels Bohr,
he just finished his Ph.
. in Copenhagen, and he had won
himself a postdoctoral fellowship,
courtesy of the Carlsberg Brewery
foundation. Carlsberg Brewery for
many years has sponsored scientific
research through the Carlsberg
Foundation.
So, Niels had a Ph.
. and a Carlsberg Foundation
Fellowship. And he decided,
well, I'm interested in modern
physics. There is some conflict in
the air. One of the proponents is J.
J. Thompson. One of the proponents
is Ernest Rutherford.
I know what I'll do. I'll spend
six months with J.
J. in Cambridge, and I'll spend six
months with Rutherford
in Manchester.
And that's what he set out to do.
So, he goes to Cambridge, and he
spends six months with Thompson.
And then, he heads up north. And
then, he spends only three months in
Manchester, not because he didn't
like Rutherford.
Actually, it was quite the contrary.
He far preferred Rutherford to
Thompson. But,
he got a teaching job,
and so he zoomed back to Denmark to
assume his teaching duties.
And, during the time of his
interactions with Thompson and
Rutherford, he got to thinking about
a way to explain the observations of
Rutherford. And so,
he finished the manuscript back in
Copenhagen. In Copenhagen,
he completes the manuscript and -
I'm going to write MS for manuscript
- completes the manuscript,
and submits this for publication.
It's a paper that describes a model
to explain the results.
So, you see how we are oscillating
back and forth?
J. J. Thompson,
model. Rutherford,
experimental data. Now,
Bohr comes with a new improved model.
So, obviously,
what's going to have to happen next
is some more data to test Bohr's
model. So, first of all,
let's take a look at how we conduct
science. I said Bohr
came up with a model.
How do we find out about it?
Did we read about it in the New
York Times? Did we see it on the
nightly news? No,
people publish, and this is the
publication of Bohr's model.
It's in a scientific journal that
goes back to the 1600's.
It's called Philosophical Magazine
and Journal of Science.
People just know it as Phil Mag.
It's 1913. It's London, Edinburgh,
and Dublin. You see Ireland was
part of the United Kingdom at that
time. So, Dublin was a British city
at the time this is published.
All right, July,
1913, blow this up,
so On the Constitution of Atoms and
Molecules by N.
Bohr, Doctor of Philosophy,
Copenhagen, asterisk here, and I've
blown up the bottom of the page,
communicated by Professor Ernest
Rutherford, F.
.S., Fellow of the Royal Society.
So, only a member of the Royal
Society could read the paper into
the proceedings,
into the session of the society for
subsequent publication.
And, this was July 1913.
So, we're going to read.
We're going to read this together.
I want you to see how science is
conducted. So,
introduction, "in order to explain
the results of experiments on
scattering of alpha rays by matter,
Professor Rutherford," and there is
a footnote to the Rutherford model.
So, if you go and read Phil Mag
669-1911, you'll see Rutherford's
model as it's presented.
"Professor Rutherford has given a
theory of the structure of atoms.
According to this theory, the atoms
consist of a positively charged
nucleus surrounded by a stream of
electrons kept together by
attractive forces from the nucleus.
The total negative charge of the
electrons is equal to the positive
charge of the nucleus.
Further, the nucleus is assumed to
be the seat of the essential part of
the mass of the atom,
and to have linear dimensions
exceedingly small compared with the
linear dimensions of the whole atom.
This is beautiful writing. It's
crystal clear.
It was written by someone almost
100 years ago whose native language
isn't English.
You can read this and you can learn
because it's well-written.
I invite you to read.
If you go to the library,
they have books. They have all of
this. "The number of electrons in
an atom is deduced to be
approximately equal to half the
atomic weight.
Great interest is to be attributed
to this atom model.
That's scientific talk.
When someone says great interest,
that's a euphemism for embroiled in
controversy.
They don't say that nobody believes
this. They say great interest.
"For, as Rutherford has shown the
assumption of the existence of
nuclei, as those in question seems
to be necessary in order to account
for the results of the experiments
on large angle scattering of the
alpha rays. In an attempt to
explain some of the properties of
matter on the basis of this atom
model, we meet,
however, with the difficulties of a
serious nature arising from the
apparent instability of the system
of electrons, difficulties purposely
avoided in atom models previously
considered, for instance,
in the one proposed by Sir J.
J. Thompson."
That's almost a slur.
That's almost saying there are
difficulties, and you didn't treat
them either. You just kind of swept
them under the rug,
but now, you are out there in full
force with your knives sharpened.
If you're so smart, why didn't you
explain it? All right,
so they go on, and on, and on in
talking about stability.
But here's the brilliance.
Here's where it comes.
"The result of the discussion of
these questions seems to be a
general acknowledgment of the
inadequacy of classical
electrodynamics in describing the
behavior of systems of atomic size.
So, he basically says, you know
what? I can't explain this because
classical physics doesn't work at
atomic dimensions.
He says, I plead guilty,
but your physics is useless at this
length scale. So,
we are even. Now, let's start all
over.
Size dependent behavior: that's what
nanotechnology is about,
isn't it? If everything is the same,
you know, when you were a kid
someone would say,
which has a higher boiling point,
a quart of water or a gallon of
water? And the answer is,
well, water boils at 100íC,
ha, ha, ha. Well, guess what?
If I get you down to a cluster of
about 30 water molecules,
the boiling point is a function of
the size of the water droplet.
Now, that's new.
That's new. But normally,
no. So, Bohr came way ahead of the
game. Now, let's take a look at the
Bohr model of the atom.
Let's see what's in there.
Here it is. These are the Bohr
postulates. And,
the stuff will be posted at the
website so you don't have to copy it
all down. It's just taken out of
the reading of lecture notes.
So, it's a planetary model.
And, it involves a single electron
orbiting a positively charged
nucleus. OK, this is the Bohr model,
Bohr model of the atom is planetary
or nuclear. OK,
and it's got one electron only,
one electron only. You've got to
learn to crawl before you learn to
run. But, it could be not
just atomic hydrogen.
First of all, I want to point out
that this is not to scale.
Marsden told us that this distance
here is about 10,
00. So, we get a little speck here
and an even tinier speck here.
So, this is not to scale. So,
this distance here is R. This is
the radius of the orbit in which the
electron travels.
And, so we have the positive charge
in the center.
I'm going to, just for convenience,
call that Q1. And, that's equal to
the product of the proton
number times e.
In other words,
this could be any one electron
system. You say,
well, wait a minute,
what's he talking about?
OK, atomic hydrogen, one proton,
one electron. But, I'd give you
another one electron system.
You learned about ions last day.
If helium loses on electron, what
do we have? We have a helium
nucleus and one electron.
So, helium plus is a one electron
system. What about lithium 2+?
That's a one electron system. Well,
my favorite is unununium, 110+.
That's a one electron system.
OK, so all I do is I take into
account that I've got all the
positive charge,
whatever it is, it's a nucleus.
And the negative charge is always,
Q2 is always equal to minus e
because it's a one electron system.
Who's buried in Grant's tomb? How
many electrons in the one electron
system, right?
So, there it is.
So, this has got protons and
neutrons. But the neutrons,
it doesn't matter about the neutrons.
And don't ask me,
well what about the relative
dimension of this?
At 10,000 to 1, who cares?
It doesn't matter how big it is.
So, what we're going to do is we're
going to go through the derivation
of that next day.
But I think at this point,
it's probably a good place to stop.
And, I will go through the actual
line by line derivation not because
I want to do derivations in class.
I will only do them on one
condition, and that is I want to be
able to teach you what the
assumptions are that underlie the
points in the derivation.
But I'm never going to ask you to
derive things.
But, I'd ask you,
since the class doesn't end until
11:55, there's no need to be
gathering things up and snapping
binders and so on.
I know you want to get on with life,
and you're onto the next thing,
and you are tuning out, but you hear
all the click,
click, click, click,
click? There's actually one or two
people down here that are feigning
interest. I'd kind of like to let
them hear. So,
let's be good neighbors.
So anyways, Bohr ascended to the
heights achieved only by Einstein.
Bohr and Einstein were considered
the top two physicists in the world
through the first part of the 20th
century. If you go to Denmark and
you break a $100 bill,
you're going to be given one of
these, undoubtedly,
the 500 kroner note,
which is worth about $75-80,
and it has Niels Bohr on it. And,
if you look carefully, it tries to
give the sense of a one
electron system.
Here's a young Niels Bohr.
Here's Bohr with Heisenberg,
and we'll talk about Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle.
Heisenberg post-doced with Bohr.
These people all moved from one
capital to another.
This one here, that's Einstein.
This is the two giants of modern
physics: Einstein and Bohr.
Check out the hats. There is a
Homburg and there is a Borsalino,
really cool. Here's Bohr mixing it
up with royalty.
There is a young Queen Elizabeth.
There's Prince Philip,
and this is some Danish royalty in
the back. I never got invited to
their place so I don't know them.
Bohr liked music. He and Louis
Armstrong are discussing
quantization [LAUGHTER].
In the year 2000, the play by
Michael Frain,
Copenhagen, is set in Copenhagen in
Nazi occupied Germany where Niels
Bohr is in discussion with his
former post-doc and student
Werner Heisenberg.
And, you can see the stage set here.
There is Bohr at the center, and
there is Heisenberg who is the one
electron orbiting the center.
And then, there is Bohr's wife who
is the observer.
Heisenberg gave us the uncertainty
principle, which we will visit later.
And so, it's a very interesting
play about the morality of
developing nuclear weapons.
And, what does modern physics
really have to give us?
A couple of other things about
hydrogen: hydrogen also,
like other elements, has isotopes
and we already saw that in 1766,
Cavendish isolated atomic hydrogen
and enunciated some of its
properties. He was in London,
and as I mentioned, he deeded his
fortune to the Cambridge University.
And, Cavendish Lab is there to this
day. In 1931,
at Columbia University,
Harold Yuri discovered this isotope,
which has two.
It has an atomic mass of two
deuterium. And then,
in 1934, it was Ernest Rutherford -
by the mid-30s,
J. J. Thompson had retired.
And, Rutherford was invited to
occupy the chair and be the director
of the Cavendish Laboratory.
So, he ended his career in
Cambridge.
It is said of Rutherford,
it is said of Rutherford that he is
unique among Nobel Prize winners
that when you look at what he did
here with the experiment of the gold
foil, and how it was able to
engender the insights of Bohr,
that, yeah, he got the Nobel Prize
in 1908 for the decomposition or
disintegration of matter,
but people generally say Rutherford
did his best work after he got the
Nobel Prize. And,
here he is in 1934 with the
discovery of tritium.
Last comments: hydrogen,
now here, I'm using a little bit of
license here. We've been talking
about atomic hydrogen,
H. Later on, we'll learn that
hydrogen as we typically encounter
it is H2, the molecule.
And, you've undoubtedly heard a lot
in the public press,
and even in the political dialogue
such as it is these days that
hydrogen might be on environmentally
friendly fuel.
And, even Cavendish,
one of the things that he observed
was that hydrogen could be combusted
to produce water vapor.
So, you might say,
well, gee, why don't we just power
our cars with hydrogen,
use an internal combustion chamber.
But, in an internal combustion
engine what happens is we don't have
an oxygen tank.
We, in fact, borrow oxygen or steal
oxygen from the air free of charge.
But, as you know, air is only 20%
oxygen, the balance being nitrogen.
And so, that nitrogen goes through
the combustion chamber.
And, although you think that
nitrogen, I mean,
it's an inert gas.
Well, if you get the combustion
chamber hot enough,
in point of fact, there are some
reactions between nitrogen and the
oxygen. And so,
you make not only water vapor,
but you make some nitrous oxides,
NOX, or nox as it is known, and this
is the precursor to smog.
So, if you want to attack urban air
quality, this is probably moving in
the wrong direction,
OK? So, people are talking about
the use of hydrogen in fuel cells.
And, we'll talk about fuel cells
later in the semester when we do the
unit on redox reactions
and electrochemistry.
But, there are some issues here.
Putting hydrogen onboard an
automobile, it's one thing to have
hydrogen in the tank.
But, put it on a vehicle and keep
that vehicle crash-worthy.
If the vehicle in the unfortunate
circumstances of a collision,
has to be able to maintain the
security of the hydrogen,
which means more mass, which means a
lot of the efficiency
is being squandered.
What's the environmental impact of
hydrogen production?
Do you get hydrogen on the hydrogen
tree? Where do you get it?
Electrolysis of water, catalytic
decomposition of hydrocarbons?
Well, electrolysis of water
consumes energy.
Where does the energy come from?
It's electrical energy. Burn coal
to make it, catalytic decomposition
of methane, you get the hydrogen,
where does the carbon go?  Goes up
the stack as CO2.
So, one of the things that you can
do is to become technically literate
so you can become part of the
discussion and help formulate
sensible policy.
Put something on the road that
metaphorically we can all follow.
And last is cost, last is cost;
hydrogen is not cheap.
So, with that, I think I'll leave
it until Wednesday.